what we're looking at here is what we
call the fiberglass core which is
basically a fiberglass skeleton and on
top of that we've got the sculpted foam
latex skin so they're actually putting
it in sections gluing all the sections
together and that's how we get the final
look of the puppet this is actually hard
material this is supposed to be like
bone when the robot moves around we need
it to move inside each other and to move
around with the softness of the skin
underneath
this is the yeah eye it's been designed
with this cnc cut jig so that every time
we pull an eye out they're always
exactly the same everything lines up
perfectly we've got another former under
there that is a mould of what would the
animatronic would be that controls the
eyeballs i think eyes wide open is how
we do it
these are the giga teeth each individual
one is different and as you can see
they're numbered here and they're 60 14.
so each one will have to be glued up
through the foam latex into the core
underneath
you